what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with Chism one of
the things we talked about in the first
video is that this is literally of
almost a perfect continuation of the
Justice League back up series which is
kind of crazy
it felt like that was the case that's
kinda how it felt you know reading the
first story and then you pick up with
this and like Savannah and it's like
yeah so it's basically a perfect
continuation now at the end of the first
video or really the end of the first the
first comic we essentially had like the
return of Billy Batson father who had
just kind of showed up on his doorstep
on the doorstep of his foster parents
and said like I'm here for Billy and
it's kind of cool because one of the
things about Geoff Johns Ronnie it's one
of most important things about Geoff
Johns riding is he's very much like
Chris Claremont right like refocuses
more on the characters and then focuses
on the story second and this is cool
because one and makes it characters
relatable and two it gives you a reason
to care about what happens to them and
then care about what happens in the
story and so with that happening like
the foster parents a billiard like
freaking out and it makes sense right I
mean like if you were a foster parent
and and you had like a biological parent
show up on your doorstep and say like
I'm here to see my son there's not a
whole lot you can do that if the if the
parent is is it's considered of sound
mind by whatever agency's determine that
then you would have to give up your kid
and it's kind of crazy because as time
has progressed
Billy's changed a lot over the years and
I was one of the big things about his
character is that he initially started
out very rebellious and very much
against the idea of like anybody in this
family and then as time progressed began
to grow closer towards them especially
when they became a part of the Shazam
family proper at least the younger kids
did and so Billy's essentially like made
a home here and to suddenly be yanked
away from that and so for his character
when the time comes when he meets his
dad which will come then that's gonna
turn into a very confusing situation
because on one hand he's gonna be like
this is my family though and on the
other hand be like you know well this is
my dad so it does kind of create for an
interesting look in terms of like where
the story's gonna go and how they're
gonna relate now for the Shazam kids
themselves they're still down and what's
basically the rock of eternity
discovering that giant map with the
magic lands and of course when they're
given like all these different locations
one of them is called fun land and
they're like let's go there which is
exactly what I would do let me tell you
something man
like if there was a place called fun
land where like all you do is have fun I
mean technically it's called Disney
World but like if all you did was have
fun like I would go there and just never
leave I would be like so this is my home
now everyone I've ever known well I
would take Mariah with me I would take
Mariah with me then I would be like okay
like we're leaving everything behind and
we're going to we're going up we're
gonna go to fun land I'll really go to
fun land and we're gonna
gonna have fun like we're just gonna
ride roller coasters and stuff like that
which it looks like it would be cool
because like like once they actually get
there dude it's like it's dude it looks
like the most fun ever let me just look
at this place like there's
rollercoasters and balloons and like
candy and like really tasty food and
things would probably make your teeth
rot out but and there's a teacups and
and all kinds of it looks it looks like
the most fun ever like it looks it looks
it looks pretty awesome like it looks
pretty amazing ah I want to know down in
the comment section in the comment
section would you guys abandon your life
and everything you know like every
friend you've ever made and all that
kinda stuff
would you guys abandon that holes by all
that stuff to go hang out at Funland
like what lights would you go to to hang
out in Funland like where you get to
ride rollercoasters and eat candy all
day long I'm kind of curious I'm really
curious what you guys would end up doing
here like I'm gonna ask Mariah that
question like when Mariah abandoned
where she abandoned me and everything
she knows to go hang out in Funland I
feel like I feel like she would say yes
I feel like I feel like she would say
yes she'd be like rob has been real and
it's been good but it ain't been real
good that would be crazy so so getting
into alright this is something a little
more important you're kind of getting
into like the history aspect of this so
what we end up doing is we basically
pick up with with what looks like a
doctor's office and we pick up with dr.
sivana
now dr. sivana as he's shown here
doesn't really seem to be operating in
the way we would normally expect which
is to say him basically like plotting
and scheming to find a way to take out
billy batson
and the reason for this is really kind
of revealed when we end up finding out
he's under the influence of mr. mind
now mr. mind goes way back to like
Captain Marvel Adventures number 26 in
1943 now back then when he was created
by Otto bender he was just kind of like
just one of Kent one of several
characters who were there just for the
sake of telling a story right like
that'sthat's 1940s comics right like for
the most part they were usually one of
us and that's why mr. mind and these
what is it the Society of monster evil
monsters or the monster Society of evil
whatever it is that's the reason why
that team is so important is because
prior to that whenever you had villains
who showed up in comics for the most
part they didn't exist as teams they
were just individual villains who had
faced off against a hero and the villa's
would generally be creative for the
story when it came to like the Society
of monsters or the evil Society of
monsters whatever was it was the first
time in the
three of comic books that a single team
had been created there was composed of
villains who had faced off against
superheroes consistently and so that's
why I missed her mind while he hasn't
always had the most significant role in
DC Comics he's really more of like a
legacy character well he's one of those
characters that changed the dynamic of
comics and usually when it comes to when
it comes to the comic book industry as a
whole those characters always seem to
kind of hang on like star row in the
Justice League star Oh sucks he's well
for the most part he kind of sucks
usually he sucks but he's like a giant
starfish they can use mind control but
while that's not particularly special in
and of itself what makes him important
is he's the first villain the Justice
League ever faced and so he's a legacy
character he carries on throughout the
comic landscape and always will there
for no other reason just because of the
legacy that he created by being the
central villain by which the most
popular team in the history of were
really the most well known to you in the
history of comics had ever had unified
and face-off against now one of the
things that I want to do here is I want
to kind of talk about mr. mind for a
second and why it matters that he's here
so for the most part again mr. mind I
mean he had his monster Society and that
kind of stuff any kind of waxed and
waned the biggest moment of his
character came out of Infinite Crisis
and 52 so when it came to Infinite
Crisis you of course had crisis on
Infinite Earths
and crisis on Infinite Earths so the way
that I like to explain it to people is
crisis on Infinite Earths destroy the
multiverse Infinite Crisis brought it
back and Final Crisis made the heroes
aware of the return of the multiverse
with Infinite Crisis being brought back
the problem was at windows those
duplicated earths arrived when they
appeared they were all for the most part
identical to the to the main DC Universe
the role that mr. mind played when it
came to the events of Infinite Crisis in
52 is he literally consumed portions of
those universes histories thereby
changing them and making them each
unique and different and so the reason
why this happened is because she's
basically like a Venusian worm and in
and of itself that just kind of imbued
him with a few powers telepathy things
like that the difference here is that he
essentially was imbued with like all the
powers of some totality of the powers of
his own race and then in turn made him
godly powerful and so what he had the
ability to do was jump from one host
body to the next and then seize control
of that person their abilities and their
powers and their their mind and then use
them for his own ends now in the future
he ended up achieving like this giant
you know worm form whatever was and
that's what he was consuming universes
but following you know what's what's his
role was served was basically he served
as the vector by which each different
universe could be made made its own each
different earth can have its own history
so to speak but he was essentially sent
back to the very
when dr. sivana first found him and then
put inside some bottle or something like
that it's weird but nonetheless the fact
remains that in this instance this kind
of ties into light the new 52 right so I
like in the new 52 dr. sivana was
looking for a way to stop a calamity
there was him that would impact his
family I'm pretty sure he discovered
magic the tomb of Black Adam at least he
thought it was a tomb of like Adam he
was hit with some magical energy and
made him blind in one eye but he can see
magic which is why as I close that way
and the result is that he eventually ran
into mr. mind
and so mr. mind has since been
controlling him ever since that happened
and then I'll really kind of took place
at the rock of eternity right like when
Savannah went to the rock of eternity
tried to gain entrance he heard some
disembodied voice it turned out to be
mr. mind mr. minds seize control of him
and he's been controlling him ever since
and so that's really kind of like how
all that comes to bear now the reality
of this is that it'll ultimately lead to
some massive calamity or something like
that and the Savannah will officially
step into his classical world when he is
you know the green goblin to spider-man
so to speak when he's like the
arch-nemesis of of Shazam of Billy
Batson but again is you know kind of
switching back to Billy and then proper
this is a cool little thing here I mean
again there's not a lot to go on with
this story it's more or less just them
just kind of having like an amazing time
and just like eating cake and all that
kind of stuff and just kind of going
nuts and having having a great time all
the things that I would do I feel like
in a place like this this place is like
Magic Kingdom on steroids like you go to
Magic Kingdom and it's like okay so like
I was an adult and then like I walked
through the gates and now I'm like a
child and you're watching like the fest
was like the parade of fantasy oh my god
the parade of fantasy you're like do the
parade of fan let me tell you awesome
two weeks two weeks on me and Disney
World me where I go and Disney one for
Valentine's Day two weeks and I am man
I'm so hype dude magic ain't no kind of
magic you know the food and the candy
and and the Pirates of the Caribbean and
all I got it's gonna be so cool anyway
with him going through here and then
really it's kind of a funny thing is on
1/2 you've basically got kids having
like what is essentially the time of
their lives on the other half it's like
but maybe there's something off about
this place like we should figure out
what's going on here so kind of poking
around and looking around what we end up
doing is running into King kid who's
like this seventh champion of the family
he's basically been missing all this
time it is Geoff jars throwing in like a
new member of the Shazam family now what
his powers are we don't really know and
that's what makes it kind of cool is for
the most part when it's come to Shazam
all the members of the Shazam family
essentially have the same powers to a
degree they might waxen wage and change
a little bit one might be like the
strongest of them the other one might be
like the fastest of them and then Billy
Batson is like basically Super Mario
where he's like the all-around character
it kind of fluctuates based on different
members of the family but we don't
really know what this what this kid's
powers are because everybody else really
kind of has a gimmick covered and so
when you go into this this enigma this
scenario it's well maybe he has the
ability to like control a universal
space or like created a mention or
create like dimensional gateways or
something along those lines we don't
really know it's really anybody's guess
here but I am excited to find out with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come let's explain make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]